un couple originaire de sherbrooke a été
sauvagement attaqué par un ours noir
alors qu'il prenait part à une
expédition
l'animal a d'abord attaqué la tante de
francine et roger gagnon puis a mordu la
dame à la jambe
on va revenir sur cette histoire avec
monsieur gagnon lui même
merci beaucoup monsieur gagnon je
remercie énormément de partager votre
histoire avec nous vous êtes maintenant
rendus chez vous premièrement la
première question comment avoir votre
conjointe francine ma conjointe guérit
bien dans les blessures était quand même
assez sévères ça va laisser des
séquelles des cicatrices n'y pas de
séquelles permanentes donc la guérison
vos pieds ça c'est la bonne nouvelle
racontez nous un peu cette nuit
d'horreur que vous avez vécu tous les 2
vendredi
juste pour préciser mais nous étions au
labrador
un voyage de canaux de 18 jours nous
étions accompagné de deux amis
donc nous étions quatre et ils puis à la
10e journée pour le soir la nuit était
2e journée du voyage
il était environ 10 heures le soir la
nuit est tombée
puis un autre sort attaquer directement
la tente sans aucune forme de
provocation des incitatifs à notre
connaissance il n'y avait pas de
nourriture également à l'intérieur
quant aux campeurs grande expérience
nous prenons toutes les mesures de
sécurité pour éviter une hausse peut
s'attirer directement vers nous des
choses comme cela
c'est la première fois que vous avez
vécu ça l'art continue à raconter donc l
ours car emma qui a déchiré la tante etc
avec l'os et était devenu le syntra deux
portes
donc les lots c'était sur la porte aux
roues était situé ma conjointe du côté
de ma conjointe le frapper l'attend le
sur le coup on a on a crié ça fait en
sorte que l'ours comme hésité à cesser
leurs attaques temporairement ce qui on
a constaté aussi qu'il semblait
contourner la tente pour aller vers
l'autre porte du côté où je me situais
et qu'on en a profité nous sommes sortis
du côté où l'ours était initialement à
ce moment même une sortie on nous
ressort à entrer dans la tente long
en passant au travers de la seconde pour
traverser la tante nous à ce moment là
mais on garde un lot visuellement
contact avec l'agent dont 60 ans
visuellement qui faisait prier noir mais
ont reculé vers notre campement quitter
si tu mets campement l'emplacement où il
y avait en effet laissé nos choses effet
le feu la veille et tout en criant pour
le un peu effet résister l'os et avertir
nos compagnons qu'on était dans une
situation lors on a besoin d'assistance
il est plus basse étant à reculant comme
ça que évidemment c'est pas facile on
est né nu pieds en réduit son on a à peu
près simultanément - ma conjointe tomber
à la renverse
si à ce moment là que l'os en a profité
pour mort de france yen à la jambe
à ce moment là moi je me suis relevée
puis j'avais vu j'ai eu l'occasion de
tomba de mettre la main sur un groupe
bio de boileau un gros de pièces de bois
trois quartiers de l'europe et à 4,5
pouces de diamètre puis quand je me suis
relevé l'osce et m'a laissé ma conjointe
qui s'est dirigé vers moi l'auberge du
jeu les frapper à la tête
ce qu'il offre qu'il a fait fuir
temporairement des cinq anneaux amis de
venir nous rejoindre
[Musique]
on croyait ce moment là que l'incident
était terminée que l'ours était parti
définitivement d'allumer un feu on ne se
soigner les blessures de france aisne
puis on avait quand même décidé qu'on
regarderait le feu allumé congrès d en
rester éveillé toute la nuit pour aux
causes où effectivement l'os est revenu
le noir c'est les toute la nuit
il a fallu constamment leur poussée sais
pas s'il attaque mais ces approches leur
semble ça a duré jusqu'à 21 ans durée
pendant sept ans jusqu'à 5 heures du
matin et qu'avant vous avez fait pour
s'enfuir
vous avez fait une chute à kano comment
on peut le faire
monsieur gagnon pour garder la tête
froide lorsqu'on se fait attaquer comme
ça par un ours
qu'est-ce qui nous viens j'y réponds je
dirais pas qu'on regarde à cette fois ci
il ya une part il ya un stress énorme
je dirais plutôt que c'est une c'est un
mélange d'expérience et de chance qui
fait que finalement on a relativement
bien réagi on ne fuit pas mal de bonnes
choses à notre connaissance
puis qu'on appuie sans tirer
relativement élevé mais finalement
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire justement
comme conseils d'usagé
qu'est-ce qu'on peut qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire si on rencontre nours dans le
bois vous avez agi correctement mais
c'est beaucoup une question de
circonstances bon on peut dire un
nouveau des attaques mono rencontrer des
10 écoutez ça fait 40 ans qu'on fait ce
genre de voyage dans un milieu sauvage
on en a rencontré des dizaines d'ours
on était déjà même notre jiren quatrième
contacts rapprochés intervention
l'interaction dirait quelqu'un ouvre de
manière rapprochée
les trois premières fois c'était bien
conclu de manière beaucoup plus aisée il
faut ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
2,2 forme d' attaques possibles une
attaque dos à caractère défensif
ça veut dire on est surpris l'eau sont
neufs
on l'est on les met dans une situation
où il se sent lui-même menacé qui nous
attaque pour se défendre
donc une attaque à caractère défensif
c'est souvent là tacle est plus fréquent
qu'on ne subit nous cette nuit là c'est
une attaque à caractère offensif qui est
assez un normand qui c'est rare que ça
arrive et c'est très très rare pour ça
arrive que ce soit un ours qui est déjà
été en contact avec l'homme qui a déjà
fait une association hommes nourriture
dont qui il associe sa présence de
l'homme à la possibilité de trouver de
la nourriture
tu es en plus il faut que le contact
avec l'homme était de nature à lui faire
perdre sa crainte de la mexa c'est ce
qu'on pourrait appeler le losc près les
situations où le speck le plus dangereux
il s'est entouré de nourriture parce
qu'il ya présence d'hommes et ils n'ont
pas peur de l'homme
c'est clair que dans ce que si c'était
cet ours d'or a été dans cette situation
là est ce que vous pensez en terminant
également est ce que vous pensez à
partir en expédition malgré cette
mésaventure
oui absolument nous on considère que
c'est
dépendant totalement isolé qui les
probiotiques ça se reproduit sont à peu
près autant que nous
on va sûrement revoir des ours mais
encore là des rencontres qui vont très
bien se dérouler puis qui ne causera pas
de conséquences
prompt rétablissement à votre conjointe
et merci beaucoup et roger gagnon
d'avoir partagez vos témoignages
je vous remercie on voit bon courage